[Musik]
Alarm am Gardasee
auf den ersten Blick idyllische Bilder
vom größten See Italiens über einen
kleinen Steinweg flanieren Touristen
über das Wasser vom Festland zu kleinen
Insel sanbiaggio
doch was romantisch aussieht hat einen
dramatischen Hintergrund der bei
deutschen Urlauber am beliebte Gardasee
leidet dann historischen Wassermangel
[Musik]
seit Jahrzehnten ist der Wasserpegel im
Winter nicht mehr so niedrig gewesen
um es deutlich zu machen in den letzten
Jahren waren es um diese Zeit 50 60 70
cm mehr was für den Gardasee sehr viel
ist Perry Lago di Garda in quantum den 1
cm See entspricht knapp vier Millionen
Kubikmeter
der Wasserpegel sinkt und singt
Landzungen werden frei die sonst
deutlich unter dem Wasserspiegel liegen
Inseln sonst nur per Boot zu erreichen
sind plötzlich trockenen Fußes
zugänglich
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ein alarmierendes Zeichen Folgen des
Klimawandels seit über einem Monat hat
es hier nicht mehr geregnet
[Musik]
eine extreme Dürre hat schon im Sommer
für historisch niedrige Wasserstände am
Gardasee gesorgt
der See gleich damals einer
Mondlandschaft
die fast schon apokalyptischen Bilder
gehen um die Welt statt zu baden
spazieren auch hier Touristen dort wo
eigentlich Wasser sein sollte über
trockenen Fels
Boote liegen auf dem Trockenen Ufer
[Musik]
jetzt also die Winter Dürre wieder
Trockenheit die dem See zu schaffen
macht
[Musik]
weitere Luftaufnahmen des regulierenden
Staudamms zeigen die Auswirkungen der
winterdürre auf angrenzende Flüsse
[Musik]
der salionse Staudamm regelt die
Wassermenge die vom Gardasee in den
Fluss minscho fließt und dann den Po
erreicht angesichts des niedrigen
Wasserstands im See wird in den letzten
Tagen beschlossen die ausgehende
Wassermenge zu reduzieren
von dem bereits saisonalen Minimum von
14 Kubikmetern pro Sekunde auf 9 um das
Wasser im Becken so weit wie möglich zu
schonen
[Musik]
daher gelangt im Wind schon nur die
minimale Wassermenge an um das Überleben
der dort lebenden Tiere zu gewährleisten
aus dem gleichen Grund wird im
nahegelegenen virgilio-kanal nur das für
die Fische lebensnotwendige Wasser
belassen
[Musik]
man muss also dafür sorgen dass man
zunächst einmal so viel Wasser wie
möglich spart was wir auch tun und getan
haben und dann müssen wir sehen dass
jeder Opfer bringen muss aber die Lösung
ist einfach darauf zu vertrauen dass
Gott der Herr Schnee und Wasser bringt
denn mehr kann der Mensch nicht tun
und auf Wasser von oben hoffen viel mehr
bleibt den Bewohnern und Touristen der
Zeit nicht noch wirken die Bilder
idyllisch doch mit großer Sorge blickt
man bereits auf die kommenden Monate
wenn es wieder wärmer wird die große
Hoffnung dass der Frühling den großen
Regen bringt der nächste Sommer nicht so
trocken wird und die Dürre am Gardasee
ein Ende findet
[Musik]